bueno lo que hay que decir previo a eso
es que en colombia hoy tal vez es
probable que todavía no conozcamos quién
sea el presidente en colombia sabemos
que dentro de nuestro sistema electoral
para que la audiencia nos pueda entender
hay dos procesos importantes a tener en
cuenta el de la transmisión de los votos
que es lo que sale inmediatamente se
cierran las urnas que hay que decir no
tiene validez jurídica y el otro proceso
que es el del escrutinio en donde a
partir de unas mesas jueces de la
república y funcionarios públicos hacen
el conteo de los votos para
efectivamente determinar que esos
resultados tienen o cumplen con una
legalidad incluso dentro del diccionario
del escrutinio que puede tomar de 2 a 3
días después de las elecciones de hoy se
hace también la revisión o validación
sobre los reclamos de las votaciones
dentro de ese escenario se ha ambientado
una narrativa de fraude electoral y aquí
es donde hay que hacer una claridad
importante tal vez la diferencia dentro
del preconteo y el escrutinio no
necesariamente significa fraude pero
debemos advertir que había unas alertas
que hemos enviado desde la fundación paz
y reconciliación para determinar que hay
que estar muy alertas también de que no
se puedan presentar irregularidades una
ciudad dentro de ese escrutinio de los
bots